all right citizens of the reject Nation
we just got done watching Blue Beetle
where George Lopez broke into a stand-up
comedy special for two hours to tell us
why Batman is a fact right it's a
one-man show it's a dissertation open my
eyes I had no eyes go home and burn all
my DC memorabilia go woke in your brain
expands
this is usually the idea but you know
don't quote me on that no no no no no no
no no hear it in the context of the
movie if you've got a character he is
like well he's always saying like this
is the guy character saying stuff like
that about anybody who comes into this
conversation through that BS out of the
way right now leave a like on this video
that'd be very much appreciated now
before we go into things reject Nation
for those who know me well no I love
graphic novels and know I've always
wanted to write a graphic novel myself
which is why when we were asked to shout
out the Codex I was intrigued I
specifically asked to get familiar with
the comic before shouting them out and I
am literally at the halfway point here
and I can confidently tell you this is
an awesome unique this isn't your
typical post-apocalyptic narrative it
massively Blends action horror fantasy
Western and sci-fi and probably some
other genre that I'm not even thinking
of right now that's where to put it is
imagine a world that interweaves Cold
War era apprehensions with futuristic
Innovations and Mythic beasts the heroes
are incredibly diverse from a determined
deserger and a 400 year old muted with a
tech savvy bionic dog and a powerful
sand Druid what's their daunting mission
to Vanquish this ancient demon darmuck
yet this journey is fraught with
challenges facing adversaries like the
death pawns these terrifying radiated
zombies screamers these harrowing
banshees and Chaos Reapers these giant
dragonflies oozing acid among others so
it really makes a codec Stand Out is
this unparalleled Fusion of Cold War
dread avant-gardec and of course
legendary monsters it paints his Grand
tail for this ominous nuclear
catastrophe unleashes these dark Forces
and of course urging brave souls to step
up and restore their Realms and already
the artwork and intricate storyline have
genuinely left an impression on me if
you like myself cherish and decreativity
then let's show our support on their
Kickstarter believe me diving into the
Codex will give you this unparalleled
experience so don't forget to click that
link below we gotta get our thoughts out
on this end of DC you beginning of DCU
movie it's the fulcrum point and with
the way this movie works like yeah this
could be in the DC EU or the TCU the
animals the references in the perfect
position James Gunn is right and John
give them a quick plot description of
this movie yes give it a go right Jaime
Reyes back from college challenge luck
looking for a good job finds an
opportunity at the cord building where
he stumbles upon the Scarab the artifact
that unleashes the Blue Beetle Powers he
takes it and then it chooses him he gets
the powers but then oh no what Susan
Sarandon's character she's uh trying to
exact her own special Tech that hinges
on the Bluetooth yeah and uh yeah and
then she's gonna come after him better
ruin your flow you um helped my flow so
much I think I I think I helped thank
you for that I appreciate you willing to
endure I could not have handled it at
the roles are reverse and I act one
experience of this movie a lot of act
one is not very strong it took me a
while to kind to understand what this
movie was really going for even kind of
just feeling the crowd where they
weren't even really reacting to a lot of
the jokes that were being thrown out
there and stuff it's not all bad in act
one like when you're meeting the
characters there are some charms to be
had especially you know I think
instantly with the family Dynamic of the
Reyes family that right away just clicks
it's really really strong but there's
other aspects with the way that pacing
was being done and a lot of the comedy
and the exposition things that we're
going through that immediately started
having me go this sort of feels like if
like if someone's like hey they made a
Blue Beetle movie in 2000 you ever watch
it they put on the theater for me but I
kept going let's just wait for when the
actual Blue Beetle starts going
sure let's just wait for act two and I
gotta say by the time it got to act two
the parts you see in the trailer were
Jaime Reyes you know comes into contact
with the Scarab it was pretty fast it
was really really fast the charm of this
movie quickly started to take over I
would say almost instantaneously it's
hard take over like if you just hold out
until act two you're like whoa wait a
minute this movie's becoming genuinely
fun yeah it's becoming genuinely
endearing the heart and the comedy is
actually starting to really work right
now everything that I was becoming
Center not well not everything there's
like especially things about the
villains that I want to go into that
doesn't quite work with this movie but
I'll save it right there so that way I
can let John get some opinions in here
the first 10 to 15 minutes I was sitting
there being a little bit worried because
I was like okay this is feeling a little
bit flat I can feel people performing
and stuff like that but once you yeah
get on the adventure and the family
Ensemble really gets a chance to lock
together and you get everybody in the
same room and you really start to let
the scenes breathe absolutely the movie
comes to life and that spirit that part
is present throughout the whole rest of
the movie for the moments that are like
surprisingly interesting as well as the
moments that are like oh that's pretty
familiar too fresh you guys a shirt
right now it's way better than the Flash
movie yes it's one movie it's like one
movie that has character in it the
character grows there were a couple of
times where the emotional swells
actually got to me uh I was really
enjoying it there's times here where
this movie has this nostalgic elements
that do feel like a genuine 80s sci-fi
movie at times in 90s sci-fi movie
obviously a 2000s movie and it's a
playlist it's a playlist of the earlier
films there were times where yeah you
know it's been a while since we've seen
just a pure origin film sometimes to a
fault though it feels like a Marvel
phase one film some of the best parts of
a Marvel phase one film and some of the
weakest parts of a Marvel space as well
everything that it was going for that
this that the director was aiming for
and then with the cast like the
chemistry with the family Dynamic like
the Reyes family doesn't just feel like
an afterthought I could imagine the
interviews where you hear them saying
like yeah Jaime is the main character
but the Rey's family it's like the
emotional core to it and sometimes you
hear it like that and it just sounds
like fluff it it sounds like ah maybe
that was the intent but it could
possibly all the people who already
bought to yeah bring this to life yeah
yeah it gets lost that is not the case
here they are all so integral and other
than I would say the mom who gets one
little moment to shine she's the only
player in the whole ensemble of the
family who doesn't really but the rest
of the family I mean the dad the sister
who at first I thought was annoying but
then I really grew to like her as well
she was amazing she was the standout of
the family and um uncle Rudy George
Lopez again Act One George Lopez kind of
annoying but then by the time
he's really funny and he's really
embodying this character right now he
does a great job well the thing that
surprised me so much is that yes it is
certainly about Jaime Reyes but the
Ensemble of the family is much more
present than I expected to the point
where there are times where you're
spending time with just that yeah as you
know Jaime is in different states
apparel and whatnot so like it really is
like a family Ensemble move and Jaime
Reyes it really feels like hey you know
Miguel from Cobra Kai
and it's a fun movie because you kind of
get to watch him sort of grow into the
role because it's like we've watched him
grow on COBRA Kai That's a streaming but
I'll call it TV show yeah so then this
you know starts out feeling a little bit
like a TV movie it feels a little man
for TV to feeling like an actual movie
and his performance I think grows to
suit that you see the difference with
this kind of movie is that the charm of
it and the things that work really work
to the point that
faults of this film The cons which we
will go into they're you know they come
and go the fault's coming it doesn't
it's not like the faults just dissipate
after act one and then it just it's
great from there it can be a bit bumpy
in certain moments of the movie but the
things that work just so for at least
for me and I feel like for the audience
you can feel the audience getting won
over by the experience as well it just
overtakes it it's like a Marvel phase
one movie with uh Latino backdrop
interlaced throughout the industry sure
if we did Miss Marvel during phase one
it was still kind of like this because
too I mean the cultural element is very
strong it's very it's very present in
order to return to the camera to be like
Mexico
but yeah like there is I mean it feels
natural yeah like a personality just
shines it feels like you're being
invited into you know the a home filled
with Customs that you know as a white
guy I might not be familiar with but you
feel very welcome and it feels like yeah
it's not stopping to Hold Your Hand it's
kind of throwing you into the rhythm of
everything but I think that's good it
brings everything to life and it really
makes for some great ons again if you
use Nora Ensemble but some great scenes
where they let the actors really breathe
and interact with each other The
Ensemble is so important to this film
now let's talk about like the Blue
Beetle power set itself I like the Blue
Beetle power set it's kind of like yeah
if you guys seen Jackie Chan's The
Tuxedo
it's kind of like that but more
negotiation and cooperation
yeah like requests can be made yeah yeah
yeah it's like it's like Spiderman's no
way home was like a little bit more
assertive it's a bit of tuxedo meets
meets Karen from the Spider-Man suit
meets symbiote Venom sure Eddie Brock
yeah right it's it's all those
amalgamations into one the powers look
cool my favorite parts of the fighting
were when you could tell that they were
using CGI to enhance practical uh stuck
work sure practical fight sir because
this movie does have third act syndrome
of crazy amounts of CGI yes are
happening and it's not super effective
because it does have the typical third
act syndrome of that I don't want to
make it a bash vest at the flash but not
to the point of the flash which that
third act I actually liked I'm on record
for saying that I actually like that
third act I know a lot of people have
that complaint but it has more Marvel
phase one uh type of effect where
characters of similar effect it's a lot
of CGI yeah yeah yeah yeah but there are
there is a lot of fun to be had with the
power set I did find myself though
craving more personality from the scare
because they do establish that slight
spoiler here I mean you could literally
look up on Wikipedia if you're like
what's the scare from my God if you do
establish it's an alien entity but they
treat it so much like it's a robotic
entity they treat it so much like it's
an Android I did find myself craving a
bit more of just give it a personality
you know the things that they're finding
if threatened by that it's gonna
overtake Jaime and that he's not gonna
have any control dollars say and what he
can do and that it could just be this
Lethal Weapon that could destroy all
there could have been more fun with the
writing to be had with the cooperation
him learning to bond with it instead of
it just being
essentially a robot that occasionally
has a line or two where you can see that
it is becoming more sentient yeah the
arc there between them kind of
co-mingling and learning to work
together it's there it's just one of the
most sparse aspects of the movie to the
point where you could almost forget
about it and not have the experience
change that much yeah um so yeah it's
like if they are graced with the ability
to make a Blue Beetle part too I will
want much more sort of back and forth or
some kind of I mean not to make it just
Venom but that has like a very strong
element of entity and protagonist
together and I feel like yeah that was a
bit missing here I thought it was really
missing they harp on what the Scarab is
quite a bit yeah yeah and it's such a
formidable presence and it has this very
unique you know set of powers and
abilities and a unique look and stuff
like that there are times where it is
really impressive what they do kind of
like a Green Lantern can just use its
imagination to conjure up weapons that's
what this Healthcare Works Anything You
Can Dream It can make yeah and so at
times it is it's pretty sweet you know
like some of the things that really
don't work Susan Sarandon I feel like
the bio on her was generic feeling yes
yeah
just be that's cold and extremely
apathetic to anyone's emotions in any
regard like there's you know everything
that every one of these to study all of
those and uh don't get too crazy with it
all right stay in the pocket it is not
red and wet I thought the villains
overall were written we Kara packs you
know there was something intriguing
about Kara packs he's craving the
indestructible Iron Man you know I think
is that character name in the comics
indestructible man the performer there
for you in front of the actor's name you
could tell that he was aiming to bring
depth to the performance the entire time
so he brought a level of intrigue
whenever he wasn't like robotic mask
just through the body language you're
like I feel like there's something
deeper here he's going for but the
writing and the treatment of his
character is not really servicing it
very requisite yeah and then way late
into the movie they decided to go here's
his character and they give you a very
interesting bit there to help the third
act kind of like okay we're doing the
big passion crash but like it's maybe a
little too late but I'm glad they put it
in it's like in the middle of the road a
little too late you're like it works it
made this more effective but it it's a
good part of this movie it was still
kind of oh so I would still be checking
out though whenever he was on here yeah
yeah yeah it doesn't fix the part where
for two-thirds of this movie I was like
oh whatever you know another big
overpowered guy doesn't make me look
back on those and go wow those scenes
are much better now yeah but from here
on great yeah
it's not exactly entirely original no I
I can't say that it's not entirely
original in fact it's actually a really
predictable movie every stretch even the
post credits a lot of stuff that reminds
you like Spiderman yeah even the post
credit scene I've turned to John like
halfway through I was like I bet you
this is what the footage is gonna be
who's exactly what the post-operative
team was so I'm not even diving into
what the topic is of it because I don't
want to possibly give away what might
happen in this film because Henry Cavill
shows up yeah Henry Cavill shows up he's
like he's on Netflix
I will say that another character too
that other dolphin just because we're at
the end of the review Jenny Court yes uh
she's another character who I felt like
the actress brought a lot to it that's
really elevated that role yeah because
99 of her character is just her telling
us her backstory and lamenting her just
reminding us that she's the good one
family yeah who's remaining right now
just pretty much shows up to give her
food in fact there's one scene but she's
like I really talk about this and she's
crying I'm like this is all you've
talked about I know
it's your backstory you know who your
father is and all these things yeah yeah
the thing is that I guess the part that
can sound like apprehensive in in the
way in my in the tenure of my voices is
because I feel like saying the words fun
and Charming are often a cop-out when it
comes to this genre when it could be a
weak film what they pitched us on the
trailers this movie did and more so yeah
I got exactly what I wanted Color Me
impressed with certain key moments of
this film the way they had the whole
character Ensemble here was just so
refreshing it was one of the most
refreshing elements was like oh wow look
the actual family around our Central
character is truly crucial to the whole
experience and they really do shine they
elevate the film and so I recommend the
movie I do I recommend it go watch it I
hope it gets a sequel because I feel
like a sequel would just leave us with a
more refined more polished version of
this yeah and I would be very excited to
see Show Low murder as Jaime Rey is you
know interacting with a potential future
Teen Titans team or something like that
he seems like a great introduction to
that idea if that's what they want to do
and I hope that this does well because
yeah the things that it does get right
it really gets right with a lot of care
and a lot of a plum and it makes up for
me for the stuff that yeah is like wrote
or that is pretty predictable or flat or
whatever else well guys uh those were
our thoughts on Blue Beetle it's a
recommendation from John and I uh what
do you think do you want to see Blue
Beetle carry on to the DC Universe leave
your thoughts down below we'll talk with
you guys soon thank you so much for
being here
[Music]